I
I want your [ __ ] to think it's
been a waste of time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're pre-empting American Music Awards
flop those not heroin using punks Uncle
Joe is here swing a dick and give it our
bubblegum on the Lord's Day [ __ ]
you should be home but you're not little
Eagles Hotel California one of the
greatest albums on [ __ ] vinyl and
here you are smoking [ __ ] grape ape
when I'll call Joey look at this look at
these little buns you take these you
shove them up your girlfriend's ass yeah
I take that look at this look at this
[ __ ] monster at death over here going
deep to that [ __ ] if you're a
teen hang up now cuz we [ __ ] around
tonight look at this oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] two
canisters of death oh look at this nut
[ __ ] oh yeah I don't know what plans
you had 10 the TV off it's all over
uncle Joey's coming into your living
room live and direct with his little
Jewish boom bah
leave mother [ __ ] syat so sit back
and get the party [ __ ] started
[Music]
were you pilot to Bombardier I'm down
yes that type of party tonight only this
one it's a little melted these are these
new things from perennial and bucks 250
milligrams you're going down you
understand look at me look at my eyes
you're going down just like that plus we
got oh [ __ ] and the stars are depth and
back for [ __ ] the holidays tomorrow
11 o'clock I mean that [ __ ] lunatic
it's a beautiful taste it's a blast of
taffy
it tastes like all the other chocolate
ship or trying to market oh yeah
it's nutritious and delicious and filled
with THC you cut the sides look good man
[ __ ] killer yep break the house
we'll use a college you see nothing
you know move on I'm always introducing
you into cutting-edge new edibles there
you go
our first man is going down listen some
people don't give out radios some people
want to funky my [ __ ] to seem smart all
I want to do and let you know what you
got available to you if you want to see
the devil I don't know about nothing
else I'm gonna lose it with a capital L
but if you want to see the devil I'm
your [ __ ] man that's good and now we
got these [ __ ] monsters if that's
Internet
we'll save one for George we go deeper
some murky waters the end of the world I
was not even [ __ ] bother you I'm
involved in the legislature [ __ ] my
to bother you but I'm telling you go get
your Monday ready mixed up the turkey
mashed potatoes and stuffing this week
they show up with something else throw
money your [ __ ] house you always get
these Gentiles that come up with a new
recipe in a [ __ ] magazine take that
magazine and show up your mother's ass
white meat jerky slice mashed potatoes a
little cranberry sauce it better be the
good kind do you shop with that dollar
store [ __ ] I'm out of your [ __ ] house
and there better be some creams
[ __ ] corn the stovetop you
better dope it up a little sausage a
little bounce on each and a little pop
us each and everybody's happy we don't
know nothin easy no [ __ ] chicken now
you talked her into a turkey turkey for
Thanksgiving you're not American
my friends they eat the [ __ ] goat but
they're Spanish so we expect them saying
I won't be going over there you don't
want to raise the goat thing kill her
with other people are you you Spanish
[ __ ] fine I'm fired up on
Wednesday night Lee's gonna be there
Simone's gonna be then there's gonna be
stars a deck everywhere hidden under
seats and [ __ ] stacked at the party give
me a minute
I gotta flip the thing I gotta be a DJ
to over
I'm back but not like the weight of a
jetties I got something my aunt
understand got [ __ ] it comes
back to - you how was everything I don't
know how everything is but you came
empty-handed cut something that's the
most important thing oh [ __ ] again one
of the greatest songs ever written right
up here was written up in Topanga Canyon
my man Don Felder wrote the [ __ ]
guitar strings send it to Hanley Hanley
listen to it so as much of a [ __ ] up as
Don Felder is this is Don Felder Don
Felder is at the top that first three or
four Eagle albums
he's [ __ ] sensational this victim a
love life in the fast it's got a lot of
great guitar work on the [ __ ] knob the
last time the black one whatever the who
the [ __ ] knows I'm stone for the ghost
I let doc desert highway Lisa at in my
car we are looking for pizza stone to
the [ __ ] gills now I got me a bum hip
and let's burn this [ __ ] up
she heard the mission bell hahaha this
could be heaven look this could be hell
are you [ __ ] kidding me then she
looked at the bomb head and she showed
me the way what that was voices on that
corridor I thought I heard them say are
you [ __ ] kidding me such a lovely
face what the [ __ ] were you doing
sitting on the couch like a [ __ ] bomb
pea collecting dust you [ __ ]
now you're up you doing some bondage the
charcoal it's Thanksgiving week cuffs up
and tight yourself up bang one out take
that old spur money in that sack that's
what your [ __ ] problem oh she got a
lot of pretty pretty boys
see Dumbo sweat some dance to remember
oh [ __ ] leave was upon him
we're going deep so I called up the
captain said bring me that [ __ ] line
oh [ __ ]
we haven't had that spirit here perhaps
but you don't see me crying make my nut
sack would you go to that hotel hotel
with my nutsack nappy I'm the older
click my button
let's give Lea [ __ ] this is the ape
[ __ ] you understand me
this is the Hardcore and this is the HT
of the schmuck I'm right now two
different worlds two different [ __ ]
world you understand me this is the
shippi astronaut smoking and training
and she said well just [ __ ] visitors
here you understand me
that's why take the stick out of your
ass a fizzle just like me only special
nobody better nobody get it we don't
[ __ ] around
leaves been [ __ ] look at that
butterflies a zipline he's ready here we
go leaf don't gonna cook them last thing
I remember goalie
look at that [ __ ] right there
there you go look at me you see I'm
saying
practice makes perfect practice makes
perfect you ever told you that that's
not true that's not [ __ ] true look at
them he's a soldier in debt [ __ ] you
take your kid oh [ __ ]
joy what's that that's wacky backy from
taffy taffy I'm gonna eat the strawberry
what do you want we will leave [ __ ]
jump mr. George you have the purple one
200 milligrams this [ __ ] will put you
and planet [ __ ] zoom buddy understand
one minute you laying there and the next
me to dance with Mexican people you
don't know how they got to look at this
[ __ ] rock the vet oh [ __ ] oh it's
expired
we'll see a dentist Imam but who gives a
[ __ ]
take away all the paper wait you ready
for another bottle yeah up yeah but
Sunday night we gotta check out your
feet or tomorrow
[Music]
we think of museum remember st. you got
your back pops up so all the time well
people think about saying - yeah thing
about things you when we start to fight
for you on a Sunday night but you know
what I'm a [ __ ] tip-top pabulum I got
the baby then oh [ __ ] around that you
Jitsu but I got a meeting at 3:00
I've got one for you I don't give a [ __ ]
they cease what this [ __ ] optimal they
can't stop
you gotta chew it off and all that THC
to go under your tongue and then it zips
into your bloodstream and it kicks off
that [ __ ] chocolate and it's a
diabetic fit now and the bong hits
grease the [ __ ] youngest and we'll try
to say to you [ __ ] when we go
deep here it's for a reason not because
you know nobody needs a rehab nobody
needs a hug you just want to let your
mind go to other places when you listen
to good music there's nothing wrong with
you here's one of the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
songs a new kid in town I'm gonna be no
new girl in town what kind of fast it
forward I don't know what but I'm happy
you're here that's the most important
thing Lee's happy you're here there's
talk on the street
[Music]
here we go here we go sorry about the
interruption oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
the life in the fast lane few cuts up
the back tremendous this is Santa
Barbara this is somewhere and will you
just want to [ __ ] run do that do that
he's gonna grab the [ __ ] Hotel and
really impress me
[Music]
and she was telling Fred
[Music]
Desilu do
oh [ __ ]
I love this [ __ ] - smoking dope with
your friends and listen to music
nobody's getting their feelings hurt
this is illegal that's what you [ __ ]
try to tell me this is illegal
this is what they [ __ ] that we got a
vote on its ready that's how [ __ ]
stupid we are but what up we're back
you 2017 July uncle joey's smoke bar
coming soon you understand me
couch is weed for bond it's comedy chick
sucking dick exactly what you like why
you're doing bondage who's better than
you
you're gonna bong at your table ice
cubes water
I got a baton I got a pot I got a little
partner here he wants to be the
dishwater gonna sell some food
inspired by [ __ ] chef ragout
none of these [ __ ] more to dos and
that's it's gonna be [ __ ] tremendous
cuz no booze weed and [ __ ] the best
food available akira me sooo you want to
put on your dick and lick it your own
thing that's how good the tiramisu is my
another monster out there as much as I
hate this [ __ ] thing even though
he's put together a good tour this year
with my man he really did but there's a
great item right here
regatta that black are you [ __ ] nuts
you might as well get the heroin out
right now Lee I know you want to bond it
stop touching my shoulder I'm sorry
you're hanging on me like a [ __ ]
pending game over my neighbor not I
don't forget nothing when it comes to
bond games I don't forget [ __ ] dick
you understand don't be touchin because
I'm sterile
[Music]
ah you motherless [ __ ] you smoke like
that nobody you know no not we're the
ones that are here in the [ __ ]
trenches like Martin Sheen Apocalypse
Now and you're over there were your
bodies jumping up and down you know
[Music]
[ __ ] nuts
let's do this [ __ ] Sunday night it's the
Lord's Day so tell and literally jumps
up and down the morning the church
always happening now jumps up and down
at night flex the muscles for these
[ __ ]
there you go show them the right place
that wants to sleep show BAM oh [ __ ] is
right [ __ ] the [ __ ] you think Phillip
two homos is get your life together this
type of bond gets here like gentlemen
[Music]
another one shoe you probably sitting
there mamacita you dirty bastard that's
what I love about you you're like [ __ ]
TV mojo be sorry [ __ ] there's bugs
flying everywhere who gives a [ __ ] you
can't walk on one leg and then mice need
to get out let's do this [ __ ] bleep do
this [ __ ] say hello hello everyone
deeply feet slowly deep take the fret
through your nose and take that one a
little bit like you do you're doing a
great lady there you go [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with your family every
day in someone so happy you're not going
to miss you just shoot do the more
you'll end up the arrows like Boehner I
got the Eddie probably gonna be a Joey
but you never even knew about you know
why they won't tell you about me your
[ __ ] pants cause they're scared you
got that right you're [ __ ] up and a
wife to this Sunday night and you uncle
Joey it's time for another bomb the
douche
to see you [ __ ] happy
Thanksgiving to you and your beautiful
[ __ ] families thank you for
supporting us myself my flying little
Jewish girl that's my girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I can't that's when you know you're
stoned when you cannot here are the
other left [ __ ] in in this damage but
you know me I complain I'm not gonna
panic it could be the edibles when you
lose your hearing that's the beginning
of that
like a mind to feel voices I can be like
the Black Swan with head chicken who is
a fifty three should supposed to start
after right now
thank God I give my great oxygen every
day one of your we for smoke and CDs and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at this - this was last time this
is like a [ __ ] snack
[Music]
we take a laptop stuff you know what we
didn't answer sighs sometimes the police
just don't [ __ ] cut it I'm saying
that's okay we gotta go deep in the
murky waters I'd be a fortune teller
what it's a good night for [ __ ]
Achilles last night it's time to go dark
why not what the [ __ ] you doing with
your life yeah don't listen to Green Day
hey I got the free you to out my lady
who gives a [ __ ] I'll be right back I'm
over you try to figure this [ __ ] out I
can't see without my glasses we go
[ __ ] in cooperation of bundesliga
people think
[Music]
it was an April morning when they told
us we should know as I turn to you you
smiled at me I use opportunity as I tend
to use mouthing let's break this roof
off and let's take this to the next
level you understand
hopefully my memories will that black
tar heroin will burn a little keeping
this [ __ ] walk you tonight will
be the best show you have a sore deal
like that it's time to kick it up boys
and girls to thousands of seven teams
here chomping presage stop the [ __ ]
bride I haven't seen Amy Schumer's
briefcase yet
Aven she surely believed them
ain't nobody going they got nowhere to
go nobody wants me understand I knew
that a long time ago nobody wants and
I'm gonna let it go I might go over to
the gentleman I'm like [ __ ] it man
what's his name
[ __ ] it officer again Richie I got
nowhere else to go but what are you
gonna do you make the best of what you
got and some day you become the king of
your [ __ ] hunt for them the
population
it's over [ __ ] 50:18
hang up right now [ __ ] I don't
want your mom emailing me tomorrow my
son blew himself up
[Music]
it's always recent in the stabbing
please look nothing like Joey you got me
sitting here like [ __ ] Vito at Ellis
Island look at this [ __ ] up give him
some Bendis with you taste this early
wait till you taste this daddy with
daddy
[Music]
this is it [ __ ] that's why they
corner oh wait did they call the
hardcore this will [ __ ] around and
you think people fold their arms will
smoke a pipe smoke this [ __ ] that you
think all these [ __ ] people you see
bacon on TV what the flavors just and
that's the most important date if you
were in Houston Friday night five
minutes before I got on stage there was
a sweet smell that overtook the [ __ ]
you understand me I showed up with some
[ __ ] they never stopped before I had the
whole [ __ ] room hypnotized before I
got on stage
why do you think I'd do that give a
little concert you ain't safe see it's
not a little weakling once you smell
Aretha you relax even if you don't smoke
reefer you relax and your mind knows
it's home I do to save the economy show
right before I go I try to smoke a
little food solutes and make the wind
blow in it and it makes you [ __ ]
crazy insane always remember there's
always [ __ ] magic tricks in every
spot that arena maybe you're a carpenter
or [ __ ] warm up to a [ __ ] travel
agent there's always smoke and mirrors
but this ain't smoke and mirrors are
here this is Jimmy Page heroin 1974 from
the [ __ ] Turks are you kidding me
[Music]
place a black hole [ __ ]
Wendy that data for cuz I wanna I want
to stuff my friend
Copernicus Mossad buckle up yourself
this is this [ __ ] that [ __ ] there's a
print smoke that night
you go
coming at you like a [ __ ] wimple and
we're still one light-year you
understanding map you join a Sunday
night
[Music]
oh [ __ ] 8:04 and your mother's a [ __ ]
how's that for you listen you know I
love you [ __ ] with all my heart
we're gonna start the podcast for about
15 minutes don't run away cuz that was
just a [ __ ] warmup you have no idea
what I got in store for you tonight it's
not I see you Wednesday night
what and guess wha were cleanup coming
get that [ __ ] porch ready that's
where they smoking reefer with eight
hands up one they got it everywhere
[ __ ] you something dickweed tremendously
we're taking it back to sixty [ __ ]
seven anyway where's the church
youtube.com slash seen slash Joey Diaz
again we youtube.com slash Lee / Joey
Diaz [ __ ] drink water you don't
want to be like me
we don't want problems escalating you
[ __ ] by Jessica tracking
and that's it that's that thank you for
joining me on a beautiful Sunday night I
hope you have a great week and a great
Thanksgiving with your fucked-up family
we say something turn into the church 20
minutes we think of that that we love
you [ __ ] stay black and thank you
for the lovely to support
I can't we can't do what